most of the things that drive people
crazy like dealing with insurance coming
are also true of Medicare hi I'm Ted
bellacor with reason TV and today I'll
be sitting down with Virginia postural
Buster L is the author of two books the
future and its enemies and the substance
of style she's former editor-in-chief of
Reason magazine and current
editor-in-chief of deep glamour net you
donated a kidney to an acquaintance of
yours years ago and factories and TV
covered that story I think it's one of
those issues that's very important but
receives very little attention do you
see since we we broadcast that piece a
couple of years ago have there been any
promising developments on the organ
markets front there hasn't been much on
the organ markets front because anything
that requires a change in government
policy is extremely difficult the most
promising area in terms of actually
getting people kidneys who needs need
them are these very complex barger
arrangements where people do chain
donations if you have one altruistic
donor who says you know I'll give my
kidney to whoever needs it you can
essentially create an indefinitely long
chain as long as there's a measure of
trust which it turns out there is a
surprisingly large one when I was at any
reason i published the occasional
article on this but it was sort of like
yeah yeah I'm a libertarian they should
do this it's bad you know you own your
body it was only when I was touched by
myself when my friends Alyssa tell
needed a kidney that I came to realize
what a huge problem ative and you know
policy and apathy and sort of ignorance
and also this sort of repulsion and
people's ignorance about what is
actually involved in donating a kidney
in 2010 as opposed to 1970 is is keeping
this from happening about a year ago you
wrote an article called my drug problem
for The Atlantic Monthly is very
controversial can you talk about the
main point you made in the article and
why readers respond
so strongly to it I was incredibly
healthy right I was so healthy I could
donate a kidney in 2006 in 2007 I was
diagnosed with breast cancer I was
diagnosed with a particularly aggressive
form of breast cancer which is called
her2 positive and for which there is
what can only be called a miracle drug
called Herceptin existence of Herceptin
I cut my chances of dying from this
disease from 5050 down to maybe five
percent if that much and I'm now
apparently cancer-free but it's
expensive my treatment which was the
standard treatment cost about sixty
thousand dollars and most developed
countries cover Herceptin because it is
so effective but I discovered in the
course of researching what I thought was
going to be an article on something else
that New Zealand which is the exemplar
of rational drug price controls and
having one of these boards that really
puts the screws to the drug companies
and it was not had not covered Herceptin
for people like me who are early stage
cancer patients and I wrote about this
dilemma of when you have these very
expensive biotechnology of cancer drugs
what happens when you have essentially a
single-payer system and somebody has to
decide bureaucratically whether it gets
treated or not and what happens is
essentially becomes a politicized
process and talk about that about it I
mean that's that's something that
Americans would be amazed at and
frightened about it was this miracle
drug was actually an election issue I
was a section issue because the the
national health system would not pay for
it you could get it if you could pay for
it yourself and then they change and
they said well we'll give you just a few
rounds of it because there is the small
study this finished study that says that
you don't really need
need that much and women in New Zealand
breast cancer patients and their
sympathizers and their doctors made it a
political issue the idea that you can
have kind of objective science weighing
people's trade-offs about whether the
caught about cost benefits is false you
can have objective science that tells
you what's the percentage chance that
this is going to work and what types of
patients that sort of thing but you know
is it worth another dollar is it worth
sixty thousand dollars well what if it
were seventy thousand dollars what if it
were thirty thousand dollars that sort
of trade off uh-huh is very difficult to
make at one-size-fits-all level what do
you say to those who say the big picture
trade-off is one between innovation and
equity and so that maybe in a universal
system you wouldn't have had as good
access to Herceptin but more people
would have been covered and more lives
that have been saved well there's a lot
in there what do you mean by a universal
system are you concerned about equity in
the sense of like everybody should be
the same or are you concerned about a
safety net those are two different
things so for example in the national
health system in the UK it is designed
to make sure everybody is treated the
same and the argument is we don't want
to people next to each other in beds in
national health and shirt l system where
one is getting treated one way and
another isn't that's a different view of
equity from what I think most Americans
are thinking of which is a safety net so
there's what do you mean by equity
there's what do you mean by a universal
system and what do you mean by cancer
tree and what do you mean by radiation
is expend radiation I'll be radiation
may be there something i don't know
maybe unbalanced it's cheaper wait well
their compliments but radiation one
thing I learned is again rainy issues
unbelievably expensive and the the thing
is
though when you're getting radiation
treatment you see why it's expensive
because the machines are obviously
incredibly expensive really complex
machines and they're very delicate that
and the and all the people working on
there is this whole team and they're all
really highly trained you know I think
our system is really screwed up it's
really screwed up because it ties health
insurance to employment oh there's
that's an artifact of wage and price
controls during world war two and what
happens is at the very time that you
need insurance if you lose your job
you're screwed so the question is really
what happens when you become uninsurable
that's or when we know that you have
diabetes or we know that you have a
heart condition or we know that I had
breast cancer damn I now my oncologist
says that I have no more chance of
getting breast cancer again added a
similarly situated person who didn't
have breast cancer but i doubt that i'm
going to convince an insurance company
that talk a little bit about your
personal experience in dealing with
navigating the world of insurance after
you survived breast cancer the most
interesting thing that happened to me
dealing with insurance when i had breast
cancer had to do with getting a wig now
the only reason my insurance covered a
wig i'm sure is that the state of
California requires it to and the truth
is I could have bought my own damn wig
ah you know that an expensive wig costs
a few hundred dollars uh you know and
there are cheap ones and I never even
wore my wig except for three times one
of which was on that reason TV oh I just
wore scarves and hats um but because the
state you know because it was in my
insurance that they covered a week I
went out I spent more money on wigs I
bought two I spent more money on wigs
then I would have spent if the insurance
hadn't covered it and then I spent
months fighting with the insurance
company to get them to code put the
right little code in there so that they
would pay this little shop where i
bought the wings it was a nightmare
when you're having cancer treatments you
just don't want to deal with insurance
companies you know one thing I would
point out one of my big lit needs during
the health care debate is Medicare first
because most of the things that are
screwy about this American system in
general most of the things that drive
people crazy like dealing with insurance
coming are also true of medicare
medicare has a million floors where do
you think all these like DRG numbers
come from
you